on vient en france avec un constat il y
a de moins en moins d'abeilles dans le
pays le sujet sérieux l'hiver dernier la
moitié d'entre elles sont mortes et
visiblement les insecticides mise en
cause à l'époque est interdite depuis ne
suffisent pas pour expliquer cette
mortalité reportage dans la marne
mallory aono daniel levy
une abeille qui rend vos sols incapables
de prendre son envol c'est une abeille
malades perdus pour la ruche clip le
compte y est d'autant plus attentif
qu'il a perdu une grande partie des
colonies d'abeilles cet hiver on a des
mortalités chronique aujourd'hui de 30 à
50% on est en permanence en train de
compenser les pertes soient hivernale
choix de fin d'hiver soit 2,8 printemps
insecticides et pesticides ne seraient
pas les seuls responsables de cette
surmortalité les ravages du varroa un
parasite indonésien et les changements
climatiques sont pointés du doigt et de
plus en plus on se penche sur le
problème des ressources alimentaires
monoculture désherbage systématique la
biodiversité végétale s'appauvrit le
menu de la bei aussi exemple le long de
cette route d'un côté les bordures sont
fauchés les arbustes arrachés de l'autre
les services municipaux ont oublié de
passer
ici à l'essai à les volontaires conduit
à une ressource importante que ce soit
du côté des arbres où on a là des les
érables qui sont pollinifères et
nectarifères ou dans la partie herbacées
on a une multitude de végétation
présentant l'intérêt pour les abeilles
pour cet apiculteur c'est tout
l'aménagement du territoire rural qu'il
faudrait revoir pour compenser la perte
en biodiversité lui a été pionnier dans
la jachère apicole sorte de réserve
alimentaire ici 20 hectares de phacélie
au milieu des blés des betteraves
nourrissent 200 ruches à six kilomètres
à la ronde et les agriculteurs aussi y
trouvent leur compte toutes les régions
multiplicatrice de semences
on a besoin énorme de ses abeilles pour
justement permettre que y ait une
fécondation de leur culture est donc
aujourd'hui ce problème de baisse de
population d'abeilles nous interpelle
puisqu'on veut on peut dire qu'elles
nuisent à la qualité des récoltes de
semences les jachères fleuries encore
marginal présente déjà des résultats
encourageants en termes de santé et de
rendement des abeilles développée à
grande échelle elle pourrait peut-être
permettre d'enrayer leur déclin
sow